women like Teeth fat rather than slim
now do you think they like I don't think
they like you yeah
they like they like okay a big butt with
a small waist that's not true yeah you
can't have a big that's a small waist
without surgery but this one here she's
got a great shape she's she's got big
butt small waist naturally is is it
depends on your state and I think you
wouldn't say it's just though
but I mean most women like to be
bigger now nowadays rather than deemed
skinny maybe they pretend they're happy
because there's body positivity I'm
happy big girls just amazing it's been
as big as Lisa or yeah
she happy okay let me ask you let me let
me she's making money one to ten what do
you rank lizzo one to ten ten
do you really think she's cries on
Instagram live oh I don't know that much
about her no I see her and she's like
are you guys do you genuinely okay do
you genuinely think she's happy at like
300 pounds how could one be happy does
she not look happy I think she looks
depressed I don't know her personally so
I but from what I can see looks wise
is very deceptive yes okay okay so so
one to ten you would trade your body
with hers
[Laughter]
you said she had a good figure yeah dude
she would be offended if you said she
looks like lizzo would you be offended
if I said you look fat
but do you think that's what it is she's
a good figure because she's so sweet
who's skinny women trying to be nice
they've done a really skinny skinny
woman yeah but you're going extreme
again no maybe it's the same thing you
said really skinny okay I would
no I think if she wanted to she'd do it
she had those she was on Tick Tock like
on the treadmill
I don't you see a whole different side
of words
you gave her a 10. what what's your
metric because she's
evident with it
anybody that's confident I think yeah
women race with feeling not logic
it comes with with how you feel that's
what I can see I was big and I'd liked
it but it's a big small what made you
like it because I was different and I
couldn't I don't go gym I hate gym I
hate anything healthy I eat everything
not healthy but I liked it then I like
it now I and I'm very confident but do
you know do you not think there's
Universal standards of beauty so when
everyone walks into the room where
everyone can kind of okay when everyone
walks into the room you don't think
everyone has a general
wait blessing can you finish this
sentence and then and then you can pause
it
perception of who's more beautiful and
less beautiful
so I meant like for her response too
sorry I don't know these days no I'm not
I'm not talking about these days I mean
in general well
yeah and okay even even take us in the
room you don't think most of us like
they could say who's more beautiful and
less beautiful and I'm not I'm not
trying to put us against each other I'm
not saying to be rated but like I'm
saying like you don't think in general
you know who the pretty friend in your
friend group is I think what she's doing
okay
why is it so hard for women to admit
that lizzo is not a 10.
and why don't we see the same body
positivity for men
oh
it's all about the woman's empowerment
like women want to feel so empowered
through I guess gears on the under the
patriarchy that anything goes there is
there's women can do no wrong in
anyone's eyes you can be fat you can be
whole you can do this you can slap up
slap up a guy it don't matter as long as
you're a woman
everything you do get Sublime
so now you just delude yourselves just
lie to each other
at your own detriment because to say
someone that lives though is attractive
and healthy and homegirl said myself
like I don't like gym I don't like to do
anything healthy that's someone to run
away from
straight away but again to say that you
might be misogynistic or blah blah blah
like anything a woman does nowadays is
yeah we like even when talking about uh
guys and relationships it's always I
feel like it's filled with excuses like
oh no he does like you it's just he does
like you but he's no he just don't like
you you just need to be straight up
about certain things
um it's a bit harsh telling your friends
I'll uh overweight no that's that's
actually a lot easier than saying um
you're ugly but I think yeah definitely
yeah you can change your weight you
can't change if your face looks like
like looks like you got smashed in with
a baseball bat
laughs
what do you think Tiana I don't know I
feel like like you said like
it's easier to judge ones like to judge
yourself than to judge someone else
because then you're kind of like you're
projecting what you view as Beauty onto
somebody else
which isn't really important I don't
know I feel like it's a very
uncomfortable place to sit in you don't
think there's subjective standards of
beauty no I do believe in them okay I do
think that like a lot of models are
really tall they're very thin
uh it depends where you are but like the
certain metrics that we can use or even
if we take like modeling out of it like
there's certain girls that men find more
attractive
because yeah it's not always necessarily
the models you know what I mean like
there's just some girls that are like
imagine yeah yeah I think we know I feel
like there's an unspoken rule like I do
think like we know who the pretty friend
is you know but then why do girls try
and take out the
the general View and try to make it
based on the individual because you'll
be like for me or just like when
generally speaking you know whether
someone's attractive or not so why do
you feel like why do women take out the
the more objective View and try to make
it subjective as possible I think maybe
I'm just gonna go for what I I think
very it's a very feminine to be
um empathetic and maybe compassionate
and
being 100 direct and honest and like
just laying down the fact is a very
masculine trait so I'm not going to go
to these two girls and tell them that
they look a certain way I'm not going to
rate them objectively from my
perspective because I just like to what
end what does that bring either one of
us here you ask the question someone
asked you a question though so why would
you lie I'm not gonna lie but I just
feel like okay after the show yeah
I think it's if you say that it's very
masculine to just uh just you know give
a very just a fact yeah and then say
it's feminine to be empathetic you can
you can you know kindly say to somebody
the truth I've done it so many times I
think there's a different dog
okay if we're talking about weight I did
have a friend who's having difficulty
putting having a child and I told her
it's because you're fat
and I'm her closest friend and she took
it and she because of I
I'm not just some strangers like saying
yeah you're fine you go girl and stuff I
apologize but um I I told her no it's
because you're fat
and you have to take responsibility I as
a friend I'm not going to sit here like
I have my own life and my time I'm
giving it to you if you're gonna sit
there telling me the whole the same
circular argument that's actually
disrespectful to me like if you're if
you really generally want to get
pregnant sort your diet out and now
guess what she's doing great
that's it so she's better looking now
would you say now that she's lost the
weight the objective was to get pregnant
and her weight was a massive thing but
it was I mean that's actually that's the
way that her weight loss has helped her
and the bonus is that she's actually
attractive so the goal wasn't to get
attractive the goal was to get healthy
and you know by result she became
attractive because she is healthy does
that make sense yeah and I told her I'm
a friend I would consider myself quite
feminine and a woman and I told her
you're fat you're ugly and I think it's
the human thing I get I think we get too
caught up with masculine energy feminine
energy what's human to do and to look
out for something I think women are kind
of more socialized to kind of beat
around the bush you know what I mean
let's be koi
um it's kind of rewarded when women were
like oh look they're not as like oh I
want this this and this I think women
are rewarded in romantic relationships
and friendships and relationships with
other people in society so if you know
that why would you still purposely like
or willingly do it really yeah so you
just said that um women are kind of
socialized to behave a certain type of
way and you know that way you're
socialized is negative in terms of
creating a better outcome for all but
yet you still sat here and still went
I think I I still do this because
obviously that's what I'm used to I find
it extremely uncomfortable to go to
someone and call them fat or call them
ugly because I haven't asked you so if I
said am I fat and I was visibly fat
you'd find it uncomfortable to be honest
with me and be like do you know what I
would find that really uncomfortable for
me I feel like say the words outside out
loud like I can think certain things in
my mind but to directly say to someone
straight up like I think you're ugly
especially if it's in negative terms
it'll be very difficult for me so we're
friends yeah so if I said if I said if I
gained that's if I gained 50 pounds yeah
and I said
did I get fat this is different because
you would you because you're Pearl yeah
Power can handle anything she wants you
to be so direct but I had German Au
pairs grown up to German nanny so I know
she can handle it so okay people don't
understand what German daddies
so I feel like it also you have to have
um a bit of tact and I feel like you
need to gauge the person as well but
let's let's role play okay oh okay
okay okay okay
set the scene
I just got rejected for the 10th time in
a row
um and he said it was because
I'm too thick
did I did I get fat I know I ate one or
two brownies
okay or ten what am I am I fat what
should be am I I don't know I haven't I
haven't I don't weight myself
do you have scales at home no okay I
have scales I avoid them like the plague
no it just gives me anxiety I can't cut
the skill okay
interesting what do you think your BMI
is
I don't know I just I don't even know
how BMI works I just I think it's like a
scale that's like not real so I feel
like they just make that up you know
doctors to be mean
okay do you think you're overweight
I mean
I question it a little bit but that's
why I came to you to get the truth
okay
you see how this is really hard for me
we see how like I went through every
other option 101 or beating around the
bush I was doing so well I came with a
BMI she could have got on the scales it
could have worked out together okay let
me let me let me try it with Eddie let
me try with Eddie
you can buy all right
so so this is you know I'm not you know
I'm just like
Yeah Eddie it's been a minute since I've
seen you how are you doing I'm good are
you telling me what I'm good how are you
I'm good I'm good
um
anyways I I was walking here and someone
called me a whale a whale yeah yeah did
I did I get fat I ain't gonna lie when I
did see you you was looking a bit more
chunky than last time I see you still
but
looks so right the pizza grown oh okay
okay so just chunky I'm not I'm not fat
no I ain't gonna lie you put my mad way
in it like drop a few drop a little
something something in you oh but mad
wait what does that mean am I am I fat
you're fat
a while
he kind of beat around the bush too I
kind of like the way you said it though
because it's playful like he was very
playful with it you were just like
you're fat and ugly yeah that's pretty
crazy
no no okay everybody scroll back and
then did I quote unquote she said fat
and ugly no I think I think me me not
you I don't know no I I did you can find
out
if I said she's fat and ugly I said she
became attractive because she's because
she's healthy does that means she would
have stayed ugly no but you said like
um I think you said like you quoted
yourself he was like no you said you
think you have to say I know I know oh
okay look back okay can we bet some
money or something
okay but now I'm playful with it
I guess I guess I respect you actually
oh thank you because it's good to have a
friend like you that will call it
straight even if it hurts you you're the
most respected friend I have to say the
thing is that there needs to be context
okay so this she tells me this over and
over again and I try to you know in a
polite way and it's like um the thing is
like I said I am not my existence isn't
to just the pacify you you know and if
you're saying that oh you know I have
this issue and my weight is this and
everything and I was like you know what
I have to cut this crap you are fat and
her radical acceptance is the most
powerful thing that's when change
actually ensued she got healthy and she
had a baby that was the objective so so
much uh problems were avoided with me
just being honest with her and if she's
an adult she's gonna take that I think
not to suddenly forget who I am a good
friend 100 agree with you I think
there's a way of like doing it with tax
that you can be playful about it but if
you're honest and real this person it
won't affect your relationship I wasn't
mean I was like you're fat you're fat
that's it I feel like if you're honest
with someone infected with a person a
relationship cannot be destroyed I feel
like if someone's real with you and
tells you something straight
if it was a real friendship I don't
think would affect it it's why you don't
do it for fear of losing that
relationship with the person the reason
I don't do it is that I find it
extremely uncomfortable I don't think
I'm I'm not used to doing it I don't
practice it
people to be honest with you
maybe not no oh you're lucky to lie to
you man them sliding them deals and sell
dreams no because I will believe those
dreams oh yeah and I don't see a problem
with that I think about it
hypothetically let's say if I think that
um
I'm like really crazy amazing like
really really beautiful and someone's
telling me dreams and I believe the
dreams he sells me happily ever after in
my delusion oh so everyone as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible